once we have a very libertarian society
I think then we've succeeded until then
we just want to educate more individuals
to the fact that libertarianism is a
viable philosophy hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with reason TV and today we're talking
with Alexander McCubbin and Blaine
Bennett of students for liberty thanks
for joining me thank you very much
Alexander what is students for liberty
we're a 501c3 nonprofit run by students
and for students dedicated to Liberty
before SFL there was really no national
organization that would help groups
start up on campus or provide students
with the resources to organize so we
were actually just a group of students
who got together and decided we were
going to help other students out and
students today care about usually the
issues that are very personal to them so
things are happening on campus free
speech infractions smoking bans on
campus campus police but also the wars
that are happening right now including
the war on drugs taxes jobs and the
future of our economy our students
optimistic about the future absolutely
think so our generation is the most
libertarian generation that's ever come
about most people are socially tolerant
and fiscally responsible we just need to
educate them that there's a philosophy
that encapsulates that I think we're
still very optimistic and and we I think
are just more realistic about it in a
way also we don't expect [ __ ] a dime of
Social Security so we're not married to
that at all and we're socially tolerant
we see things evolving more in that
direction and that to us is great how
does SFL define sick
for itself for the organization and for
society once we have a very libertarian
society I think then we've succeeded
until then we just want to educate more
individuals and open people's eyes to
the fact that libertarianism is a viable
philosophy because there are so many
people out there who believe these ideas
but just haven't raised their hands to
say I'm one of them and there are so
many people that are interested in this
our goal is to create more student
groups get more students involved in
advancing Liberty in their life so that
we can create alumni for liberty who are
going to change the world Alexander
McCubbin blame Bennett of students for
liberty thanks very much for talking
with us for reason TV I'm Nicholas B